[Musique]
si vous me connaissez je suis plutôt un
garçon qui aime le rock n roll qui
aiment la musique bien évidemment j'ai
une histoire dans l'univers du spectacle
il ya une marque qui m'a beaucoup marqué
justement c'est marshall et marshall où
j'en ai déjà plusieurs fois parlé pour
vous présenter leur enceinte et
aujourd'hui je vous présente une
nouvelle enceinte de marshall c'est
celle là c'est la marshall undertones
c'est une vidéo aujourd'hui qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec marshall
pour vous présenter cette nouvelle
enceinte nouvelle enceinte très petite
facile emmener partout avec vous on est
6 sur l'idée d'une enceinte qu'on peut
déplacer qu'on peut emmener lors des
soirées d'été lorsque vous allez vous
balader avec des amis en une petite
rando lors d'un moment convivial et bien
vous pouvez prendre votre petit marshall
hunt burton et cette marche à la marque
elle est plutôt intéressante et pour
plusieurs points déjà design iconique de
marshall bon je passe un peu le truc
soit vous aimez soit vous avez pas mais
pour moi c'est une vraie résonance 2 pas
mon histoire puis mon histoire de
gratteux quand j'ai eu mon premier ampli
marshall n'avoir pas 15 16 jan fabre est
peu importe ça on s'en fiche mais
surtout vous avez ans oncle est très
cool c'est ça qui fait plein de
promesses et je vais tout vous détailler
tout vous expliquer et je vais vous dire
pourquoi cette enceinte marshall 1
burton peut être fait pour vous
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse vous a
mis un lien en bas par la description
genou très rapidement le contenu de la
boîte bon design iconique on connaît un
peu l'histoire marshall ça c'est sympa
j'aime bien vous ouvrez votre petite
boîte on va retrouver ici il ya 1962
ceux qui s'intéressent à l'histoire
marshall alors normalement ici vous avez
votre enceinte qui est planqué là dedans
mais money jeu les enlever vous
retrouvez quelques petit dock qui vont
vous donner plein d'informations très
pratique sur votre enseigne donc ça
c'est cool un petit guide de démarrage
qui va vous guider pas à pas pour vous
dire bien quoi servent les boutons à ce
qu'on peut faire avec
alors moi c'est tout vous détailler donc
le bon sens on peut passer un peu très
rapidement vous avez un call pour mire
le recharger en usb c'est et puis voyez
on a fait pour c'est tout simple sympa
c'est pratique c'est contre l'idée de
cette enceinte c'est une enceinte que
vous allez on est avec vous c'est une
enceinte nomade on va pas avoir un son
qui va être aussi bon que sur les gros
en cinq marches allait gagner évidemment
parce que vous allez avoir des haut
parleurs beaucoup plus petit bien
évidemment donc on va pas dégagé la même
période soit pas dégagé la même qualité
néanmoins on garde quand même la
signature sonore marshall et c'est là au
marshall est assez fort pour garder une
gamme cohérente que vous soyez d'une
petite enceinte portatif comme celle là
où que vous soyez sur une grosse
ensemble de cinq ans on la tient
extrêmement facilement dans une main
elle fait zéro
2 7 kg s est faite sans g on va sentir
un peu de poids soit né comme ça mais
c'est vraiment pas très lourd et très
très facile à porter ici la façade avant
ce côté pas grand-chose à l'arrière est
ici vous avez votre port de recharge en
usb c'est sur le sulaco informations pas
grand chose est sûre le dessus ce qui
nous intéresse
eh bien ce sont les boutons alors pour
l'allumer c'est facile vous laisser ici
appuyé quelques petites secondes on
retrouve le son marshall pour venir la
paire est en blue tooth est très facile
vous faites un appui ici de quelques
secondes
il vit à clignoter et vous pouvez venir
la paire et vous avez ici votre voyant
de batteries donc ça c'est vachement
cool
vous savez exactement vous en êtes et
ensuite là vous avez des petits boutons
vous montez le volume vous baisser le
volume
vous avancez un morceau vous arrête un
morceau vous faites playes vous fait
poser les connais depuis voyez c'est
extrêmement simple d'utilisation on va
avoir des médiums aigus de bonne qualité
un son clair et un son précis comme je
vous le dis on va pas avoir un son qui
va être aussi précis se retrouver sur
les grosses enceintes marshall mais
c'est normal et par contre qu'ils
vachement intéressant c'est que comme
vous avez deux radiateurs passifs et
bien vous allez récupérer vraiment au
ronronnement ça vient vraiment groove et
je sais pas si vous allez bien vous en
rendre compte comme ça mais c'est quand
même bien vous faire écouter vous allez
voir c'est vraiment bluffant
vu la taille de la bête que ça peut
dégager comme son
[Musique]
alors je sais pas si vous vous en
rendrez compte mais vous allez vraiment
ce côté groovy on le sent on quand on
est vraiment face à l'enceinte et qu'on
écoute le son comme ça voyez on a
vraiment un truc et qui ronronne et ça
c'est vraiment très très très très cool
et c'est assez dingue sur une enceinte
de cette petite taille comme ça qu'on
soit capable de dégager
effectivement son qui ronronne vous avez
deux haut-parleurs de 2 pouces avec un
ampli de 10 watts de classe derrière le
premier haut parleurs se situe ici juste
derrière la grille et le deuxième se
situe de l'autre côté vraiment voyez le
premier là le deuxième est là donc il
situe ici vous avez vos deux haut
parleurs et vous avez ici des radiateurs
passifs un qui va situé ici et le
deuxième qui va se situer là haut
parleurs haut parleurs radiateur passif
radiateur passif
les haut parleurs vont venir dégager le
son médium aigu tandis qu'ici avec les
radiateurs passifs
vous allez avoir le son grave et chez
marshall ça ronronne et même sur une
petite bête comme ça merci aux
radiateurs passifs alors c'est bien mais
il ya une petite limite c'est que
lorsque vous allez pousser le son trop
fort vous allez venir pousser les haut
parleurs de 2 pouces grâce à l'ampli que
vous avez derrière et le radiateur
passif va avoir beaucoup plus de mal à
suivre
vous allez perdre par contre au niveau
du sont beaucoup plus graves et le son
via un peu criard c'est un peu l'idée
mais lorsque vous restez un médium moyen
fort ça fonctionne mais lorsque vous
pousser vraiment 3 fond c'est pas
terrible et je pense que c'est un peu la
limite de l'enceinte
c'est la seule tout cas gardez vous fait
écouter pas si vous vous rendez mais là
je le fond ce qui est quand même avec de
graves et lorsque j'ai bien
royer
quand je le montre au fort je récupère
que du média mais de l'aigu ça devienne
très agressif c'est vraiment quand je
passe le cap d'être vraiment vraiment
vraiment à fond mais pour tout le reste
c'est vraiment hypra cool regardez vous
allez voir là ça ronronne érables là ça
va
commençant à faire du nab
qu'est ce que je dis mais jamais eu et
pour tout le reste la même à faible
volume ça qui est assez drôle même à
faible volume vous récupérez vraiment ce
côté grave sur le côté et c'est là que
ça marche vraiment très très très bien
alors leader tout avec des amis et bien
c'est pas de la faire hurler mais vous
mettez un volume comme ça voyez c'est
vraiment très cool et l'appareil qui
sont graves
si vous allez vous la rencontre avec mon
petit micro comme ça mais c'est vraiment
extrêmement bleus force à qui veut
vraiment vraiment cool extension vous
avez un son dynamique sans voix ça
groove c'est rock'n'roll personnellement
j'aime beaucoup
alors il ya un truc qui est vachement
intéressant qu'il faut connaître ici ici
marshall à une technologie qui s'appelle
trou stéréophonique vous avez du son
stéréo
oui oui dans l'absolu mais vous n'avez
pas eu une image stéréoscopique parce
qu'ici effectivement on a des haut
parleurs stéréo mais on n'a pas une
expérience stéréo vous explique pourquoi
ça c'est votre enceinte vous avez le
gros bouton au centre vous avez votre
lecteur batterie vous avez votre petit
bouton ici vous avez votre grille mark &
marshall ici donc vous avez ici votre
haut parleurs le deuxième haut parleurs
qui situe à l'arrière
et là vous avez votre radiateur passif
deuxième radiateur passif
ici vous allez retrouver le canal gauche
left et le canal droit wright et bien
vous allez avoir un son qui va être plus
comme ça de ce côté là et comme ça de ce
côté là ce qui fait que la seule façon
d'avoir une expérience thériault et bien
je dirais c'est tenir vous positionnez
ici hop avec votre petit nez où vous
aurez le gauche là le droit mais vous
aurez pas le son qui va arriver en face
de vous donc on n'a pas d'expérience de
stéréoscopie mais malgré tout on a bien
un son stéréo qui ce soir puisqu'on a
bien la gauche et la droite
ça va apporter un peu de spatialisation
à tout ça en tout cas ça me paraît être
mieux que si on avait juste de haut
parleur mono avoué moyens d'ailleurs
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire
et tout ça ça vous permet d'avoir un son
à 360 degrés ce qui fait que imaginait
gens sont allés vous êtes en pique nique
à l'extérieur avec des ânes il fait beau
il fait chaud pourquoi pas connecteurs
froid vous faites ce que vous voulez
vous posez votre enceintes au milieu de
la n'a posé sur le sol sur une table ce
qui nous fait plaisir et faire plus et
bien pouvait être n'importe où profiter
vraiment dans son qu'il répartit de tous
les côtés la puissance sonore que donné
par marchal cdu 88 décibels à un être
vous connecter votre enceinte à grâce au
bluetooth 5.0 ce que vous permettra
notamment le bluetooth 5.0 et bien c'est
pouvoir connecter différents appareils
directement à votre enceinte je sais pas
vous est à une soirée c'est à
l'extérieur avec vos amis vous sur votre
smartphone vous mettre un morceau de que
le morceau est finie votre collègue va
mettre un autre morceau permet de
choisir de changer de pouvoir envoyer
chacun son morceau depuis son smartphone
donc ça c'est cool et vous avez une
portée de 10 mètres maximum alors on va
se dire ok enceinte qui vivent à
l'extérieur mais si tout d'un coup j'ai
une averse en orage et qui se met à
pleuvoir dessus et bien qu est ce qui va
m'arriver est ce que mon enfant elle va
craindre et ben non justement c'est un
peu l'idée là vous avez une
certification ip67 qui certifie que
votre enceinte est résistante à l'eau
alors l'idée c'était d'aller vous
baigner pendant des heures avec mais la
norme lui permet d'être immergé à un
mètre pendant 30 minutes
alors je vous le dis faites très
attention à l'eau chlorée fait attention
également à l'eau salée mais l'idée au
fait de cette enceinte c'est que s'ils
se met à pleuvoir
vous avez des trombes d'eau qui vous
tombe dessus eh bien il va absolument
rien lui arriver
vous avez une grille métallique à la
vente vous allez tout un tour qui est
fait en silicone ces résistances et bien
ça se tient très bien en main ça c'est
aussi un point qui est aussi extrêmement
intéressant ruines de l'autonomie avec
ces petites bêtes et bien vous avez plus
de 20 heures d'écouté lorsqu'elle est
chargé à fond donc là pour l'instant
j'en ai encore un petit peu ça va mais
si vous arrivez en fin de course et bien
vouloir charger 20 minutes et vous êtes
reparti pour cinq heures d'écouté pour
la recharger complètement travaux
s'armer de patience il vous faudra trois
heures bon ici par contre vous n'avez
absolument pas de micros qui vous
permettra de répondre à un appel d'un
autre côté on n'est pas du tout dans
l'adn de cette enceinte de venir
répondre à des appels si vous êtes avec
des amis entre elles partagent un moment
pas sûr que ce type depuis votre en soit
ça pourrait être un petit peu ballot
vous n'avez pas non plus deux prises
jack dont vous n'avez pas pouvoir dire
branche effectivement un câble dessus
mais on reste vraiment dans l'idée ici
de la connectivité et d'une enceinte
nomade qu'on peut emmener avec soi donc
le fait de pas avoir de prise jack c'est
pas très grave là dessus maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que c'est un
simple est fait pour vous et à qui elle
est destinée alors pour moi c'est très
clairement une enceinte qui est fait
pour les personnes qui veulent aller en
extérieur passer du bon temps mais
pourquoi pas et faire du sport en
extérieur vous la prenez vous la
possible fait de pouvoir avec le
bluetooth 5.0 est bien connecté
différents appareils c'est très cool
pour les soirées d'été où les soirées en
tout cas peu importe avec les amis le
fait qu'elle soit très résistante pour
l'extérieur aussi c'est vachement cool
apéro d'été sorties entre amis
rando balade en tout cas voilà peut vous
servir dans plein plein plein de 4
et personnellement c'est extrêmement
fans de la dignité
regardez vous la prenez la source aller
là vous la prenez vous l'allaitez comme
vous voulez je suis très très mal a vous
de me dire vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire comment vous la
trouvez cette enceinte et surtout à 149
n'auront donc pas très cher voilà pas
finalement je suis conquis ce n'est pas
ce que vous en pensez on va en
commentaire et si elle vous intéresse
vous avez bien évidemment le lien en bas
merci à marshall d'avoir côtoyé cette
vidéo atteint où je vous dis à très
bientôt pour retenir par l'état qui
croyez moi il ya plein de belles choses
karine tougas beaucoup d'amour à crédit
ciao ciao
[Musique]